but we begin tonight with dr. ben Carson
dr. Carson thank you very much for being
here
so you know I'm interested to speak with
you about this concept of reopening the
country because you are a medical doctor
a surgeon and also the HUD secretary
concerned with housing and urban centers
in this country so where do you have to
be as both of those wearing both of
those hats to look towards a May 1st
reopening of the US economy well they're
not incompatible hats you know what we
have to recognize is that their benefits
and risk in life and that's why we have
these very complex brains and we can
take all kinds of information integrated
and come out with a logical solution
it requires looking at data and
understanding how to analyze it looking
at what's happened in other countries so
when we see that that bell-shaped curve
and we've seen it come down rather
steeply in some other countries when
that happens we haven't seen it go back
up so that's what we're looking for here
that already seems to be starting
obviously we don't want to go too early
we'll wait for you know a couple of
weeks and see that it continues down and
then we also need to make sure that we
have appropriate testing we have to be
able to test people to see if they have
the virus we have to test people to see
if they have the antibodies which will
make them much safer in terms of
returning to the workforce and then we
have to return them in a logical way you
know that's the key so I want to show
you some of the new polling that we have
tonight that we just got back that I
think sort of gives you a little sense
of where the American public is in terms
of their confidence levels with all of
this at this point are you concerned
about catching Cove in nineteen seventy
six percent of the country says that
they are still concerned about getting
it this is April four to April 7 only
twenty four percent are not concerned
take a look at this next one
seventy-five percent of the country is
concerned about being able to get tested
and we heard a lot of questions on this
tonight I think this is really one of
the sort of anxiety raising issues that
still persist in the
country people want to know whether or
not they had it and they want to be able
to have a quick easy way to find out and
this last one I find very interesting do
you know someone with coronavirus only
21 percent of the country says yes they
do 76 percent says no they do not you
know living here in the New York area I
think everybody knows somebody with this
terrible virus but in the rest of the
country the numbers are much lower
doctor your thoughts on all of that in
terms of how they paint the American
public right now
well keep in mind that a lot of people
who have the virus are completely
asymptomatic somewhere between 25 and 50
percent so you probably do know someone
who has it you may have it who who who
knows but you know people have been
terrified because you know we've talked
about the bad one of the things we don't
seem to talk about a lot there number of
people who have recovered which is going
to be about 98 percent of all the people
who get it they're going to do quite
well and we need to really start talking
that up and start talking about what we
can do not how we're going to be
harnessed because the fact of the matter
is if we destroy the economic
infrastructure of our country we're
going to lose a lot more people than we
lost from this virus so we can't you
know operate out of hysteria when people
are hysterical
they don't do logical things I think
it's interesting that more people are
concerned about the economy than they
are about getting the virus I thought
that was a pretty telling number as well
I want to play this from Governor Cuomo
because it speaks to your work as HUD
secretary and some of the communities
that you deal with let's watch this
we're going to be doing more testing in
african-american and Latino communities
with more data we're going to open new
testing sites primarily in African
American Latino communities how
concerned are you about the numbers that
we're seeing in african-american and
Latino communities and in the urban
centers especially I'm very concerned
about it I was concerned about it a long
time before this because a lot of the
health disparities that occur and in
this case it's particularly concerning
because
people who live in close proximity and
people who cannot shelter at home our
people who are more likely to contract a
disease so it it will attack anyone and
then when you throw on top of that you
know a higher incidence of some of the
underlying conditions like hypertension
and diabetes obesity and asthma
obviously you're creating a situation
that is very undesirable what people
should know is that in the last flu
epidemic last year and the one before
that and the one before that and one
before that the same demographics blacks
and Hispanics had higher mortality rates
because the same things were going on at
least now I think people are going to
pay attention to it and maybe we can
address it yeah before I let you go last
question you know it's interesting when
you look at the number she just
mentioned the flu in 20 18 19 20 17 18
it was a very big flu season we lost in
the United States 61 thousand people
from the flu now the models that were
showing is showing a similar number for
kovat 19 why do you think that is and
you know what's your takeaway from that
well you know that's a question that
I've asked many virologist and
epidemiologists and I get lots of
different answers to that
why has this one gotten so much more
attention than other flus well for one
thing it's it's very very contagious and
for another thing you know this is a
pandemic it's everywhere
so your likelihood of getting it is
greater but you know it could be that
sometimes we overreact to things the
important thing is that we sit down and
we try to analyze it logically that's
what's been done that's what the task
force is therefore that's why we consult
with multiple experts around the country
at various universities and research
institutions and try to get the very
best data and use that to make
recommendations dr. ben Carson always
good to talk to you thank you very much
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development Bertha thank you sir